Okay, guys, let's get stuck into video
number 10. We've made a lot of progress so
far in the video series, but there's still
a long way to go. In this video, we're
going to get into the U.S. construction
sector, and in particular, the U.S.
residential housing sector. We're going to
be looking at our next leading indicator,
the Census Bureau's monthly report on
building permits. Let's have a quick recap
of what we've covered so far. Our leading
indicator list, we have our government
bond market with real interest rates and
the yield curve. We have our corporate
bond market with investment grade and high
yield or junk spreads over the 10-year. We
have our M2 money supply accessory. We
have our stock market volatility, the S&P,
S&P 500 VIX from the IPLT video series,
and we have our multiple survey list,
which we continue to add to. So surveys so
far, we've covered the ISM manufacturing
report, the ISM non-manufacturing report,
and the University of Michigan Consumer
Sentiment Index.
We are now adding the Census Bureau's
monthly report on building permits. So
what are we looking at here? Well, we're
looking at the U.S. housing sector. And
the U.S. housing sector provides us with
multiple economic indicators that can help
us make decisions as traders and PMs on
whether we believe the U.S. economy is
likely to grow or not.
The building permits report. The building
permits report that comes from the Census
Bureau is taken from the monthly Housing
Starts Report, which is a report that is
released on a monthly basis with a lot of
information in the U.S. housing sector.
The building permits report to predict GDP
growth and S&P 500 direction and returns.
Now, the building permits number is one of
the most misunderstood economic numbers in
the U.S.
Even pro-traders guys and seasoned
economists miss some very important
signals that the building permits data
actually gives us. Now, where can we find
it? Well, the links are on the screen, as
you can see, census.gov forward slash
construction with the URL extensions. You
just need to go there each month and go to
the History
Section of the Census Bureau section of
the Census Bureau's Construction Index
data set. You can download the entire data
set in Excel and view it from the sheet,
Permits Seasonally Adjusted or in PDF
format. And then you add the new numbers
in every month. This is easily done by
yourself. But we do have a download in the
Downloads area for you. If you want to go
there, you can see it.
We want to get the data quickly. We want
to get the data quickly. And we've done a
lot of work in that Downloads area as well
on the data to show trends. When is it
released? It's released in the second or
third week of the month. And the data is
for the previous month.
Now, before we get into building permits
themselves, a bit of background
understanding is required.
We need to understand what this housing
report is all about, the Housing Starts
Report that comes out every month.
So the building permits number comes from
the U.S. Housing Starts Report.
The report also includes a number for
housing completions.
And each of these three variables, these
three data sets, have a different
definition.
We should understand that definition
first, so you can understand the report
better.
It essentially breaks down the entire
process of a residential housing unit
being developed or built.
So we have three stages for a residential
home to be built.
We have a building permit being
authorized.
We have the project being started, a
housing start.
And when the house is complete, we have a
housing completion.
And the way we define these data sets
individually is basically from a time
perspective, okay?
A building permit is a leading indicator
because it leads the housing start.
A housing start is a coincidence indicator
because it tells you what is going on at
that moment in time in the economy.
A housing completion is a lagging
indicator because once the home is
complete and it's built, it's finished.
The project is over.
So throughout the time series, the housing
start is when there's economic activity
occurring.
The building permit precedes the housing
start, so the building permit is when the
project is authorized.
So what is the definition of a building
permit?
Well, the building has basically received
planning permission by the local state
planning department.
For a housing start, the foundations of
the building have been laid, the project
has started, the economic activity has
started.
Housing completion, the structure and the
major interior work has been completed.
So there's probably still minor work to
do, but it's not essential, and the home
is currently being marketed for sale.
So another way to look at this, a building
permit is when the paperwork for the
project is put together.
A housing start is when the physical
commodities become the house.
What do we mean by that?
Well, the foundations go in.
There's bricks, cement, steel, iron ore,
copper wiring, electrics, components, et
cetera, et cetera.
This is when physical commodities, the
economic activity starts and the house is
built.
Physical commodities turn into the
property.
Then the housing completion, this is when
the project is complete and the economic
activity is stopping.
So it's paperwork, physical commodities
become houses.
The project stops, housing completion.
So we have the paperwork, which is the
leading indicator.
We have the physical commodity
transformation into the home, which is the
housing start.
That's economic activity that's occurring
in the economy right now.
And we have the housing completion.
And that is a lagging indicator.
So we go from paperwork, leading.
Housing start, coincidence.
Project completed, lagging.
Now, given that this is actually a time
series, and as traders and portfolio
managers, we want to know
what the length of time is between a
building permit authorization, a housing
start, and a housing completion.
Because we want to know what length of
time of building permits leading indicator
is leading the economy by,
and leading the coincidence and the
lagging indicator.
Well, we can get this data if we go to the
Census Bureau website.
And if we look at the URL extension there,
so construction forward slash nrc forward
slash length of time.
And you can see we can look at the length
of time and get the data set, the length
of time that it takes for an authorization
to start.
And we can also get the length of time
that it takes, get the data for a start
becoming a completion.
So let's have a look at the data for a
building permit being authorized and the
length of time it takes for a housing
start to occur.
If you look at the screen here, you can
get this PDF download from the Census
Bureau website in the URL that I just
mentioned.
And we're looking here at the percentage
distribution of new privately owned
residential buildings started in permit
issuing places in the year of 2020 by the
number of months from authorization.
So the number of months it takes for a
housing start to start from the moment of
authorization across the United States in
the year 2020.
So let's have a look at the percentage
distribution here.
Now, there are states that allow
developers to break ground and start a
project before a building permit
authorization is issued.
The first part you're looking at here, if
we look at the headline numbers of the
United States, is exactly this.
So prior to or at the same time or in the
same month as the authorization or the
building permit is issued, this comes out
at 43%.
So you can see in a lot of states around
the US, developers from the local state
planning department are allowed to break
ground and they're allowed to start their
project either slightly before or in the
month of the building permit being
authorized.
This comes in at 43%.
If we look at the rest of the percentage
distribution for the 2020 year, we can see
one month comes in at 37%.
So that's one month after the building
permit has been authorized.
So one month comes in at 37%.
Then two months comes in at 10%.
Three months comes in at 4%.
So I've added those up and we get to 51%.
Basically, in the one to three month time
period after a building permit is
authorized.
And yes, guys, it's not a coincidence.
Housing developers are trading one to
three month portfolios as well.
Additionally, you can see that projects
starting from authorization, four months
or more comes in at 6%.
So if we add the one, two, three and four
months or more together, 57% is one month
plus, but the meet obviously is in the one
to three month period.
So essentially, if we add the 51% and the
43%, 94% of projects are started either
around the time when the permit is issued
by the State Planning Department or within
three months.
We can also look at completions.
And if you download the PDF there for
completions, whatever time period you're
sitting in, but we've got completions here
for 2020.
We can look at the percentage distribution
for the time periods for completions
coming from starts.
So started projects that are actually
getting completed and how long it takes.
So if we look at the headline data for
2020 across the whole of the US, we can
see we've got 16% is three months or less.
So it takes three months for a housing
start to become a completion that's 16% of
projects.
Next, we've got four to six months, seven
to nine months, and 10 to 12 months.
And if we add that up together, that shows
a time lag of four to 12 months.
And then in the minority of cases, we have
projects going from start to completion in
13 months or more.
And that comes in at 9%.
So the meet is obviously in that period in
four to 12 months, but really it's four to
nine months.
So we can actually get conclusions here on
the actual time lag from permits to starts
and from starts to completions.
And therefore, how much time permits are
leading starts and how much time starts
are leading completions, but also how much
time permits are leading completions.
So permits leading starts.
We're looking at three to four months.
Where does the four months come from?
Well, that's because in the data, the
state planning departments in some states
allow developers to actually break ground
at the same time or one month before
permits are issued.
So to be prudent, we're using three to
four months leading housing starts.
So permits leading housing starts by three
to four months.
What about starts leading completions?
Well, we've just looked at that.
It's on the screen.
We're looking at the vast majority of
times in the four to 12 month window.
So what does that mean for us as traders
and portfolio managers when we're looking
at building permits as a leading
indicator?
Well, it means permits are leading housing
starts by three to four months and permits
are leading completions by anything
between eight to 16 months.
So it's obviously an extremely useful
leading indicator.
Now, what does all this actually mean for
us as traders and portfolio managers?
Well, this is part of the reason why so
many players in the market misunderstand
or misinterpret what the building permits
number actually means,
because it infers a lot of useful
information for us, but people, a lot of
people in the market don't really
understand what it infers.
We are looking at how many building
permits have been issued by state planning
departments in the U.S. at any one moment
in time in a particular month for the
previous month.
And those building permits can go up month
on month and they can go down month on
month.
And we look at the change in that as well.
So we look at the total number and we look
at the changes month on month.
So by definition, the building permits
number as a leading indicator tells us
several things.
The first thing it tells us is it gives us
a very good gauge on developer sentiment,
on housing developer sentiment.
So it tells us whether or not developers
are bullish or bearish on the prospects of
future home sales.
Developers have to physically make the
application for building permits.
So more applications for building permits
means, from a developer sentiment
perspective, an expectation of future
sales.
And it costs them money, guys.
They don't do this for fun, okay?
Every single application that goes in to
the state planning department, it costs
anything between $500 to $1,000 per home,
depending on what state you're in and what
home you're applying for.
What it also does is it gives us a gauge
on home buyer demand.
So the demand for housing from the US
consumer.
And this, as a consideration from a
traders and portfolio managers
perspective,
runs in tandem with our analysis of
consumer sentiment.
Because it may eventually lead to changes
in future consumer spending.
So if home buyers are bullish, it probably
means in the future, they're going to be
spending money.
And if they're bearish, home buyers are
bearish.
It probably means in the future that
they're eventually going to spend less
money.
So tightening their belts.
But what it also does is it gives us a
gauge on the liquidity and health of the
US credit market.
And it does this in two ways.
First of all, the supply of loans.
Developers in the US don't finance
projects with 100% equity or cash.
They put down a certain amount of money
and they use a mix of that cash and they
borrow money.
They use debt.
Additionally, the home buyers themselves,
the consumers, they don't buy houses for
cash.
They buy them with debt, they buy them
with mortgages.
So the building permits number gives us an
insight into these two areas in terms of
the liquidity and health of the US lending
environment,
government, which is essentially the
health of the banking sector and the
credit markets and the overall economy in
the United States.
Now, the data itself, as mentioned
previously, we do have a download US
building permits in the downloads area
under the video.
So in your own time, download that there's
a lot of pretty comprehensive work in
there looking at the various trends and
turning points in building permits.
And we're going to go through those a bit
later.
But let's have a look at the survey design
for building permits in a bit more detail
and understand that a little bit better.
Okay, so basically, the purpose of the
building permits survey, so the report
itself,
is to give national, state and local
statistics on the number and valuation of
new privately owned housing units that are
authorized by building permits in the US.
The statistics from the building permit
survey are based on reports that are given
or submitted by local building permits
officials in response to a voluntary mail
survey.
And the data is collected from the
building permit officials.
So in this survey, using what's called a
form C404, which is the report of building
or zoning permits issued for new privately
owned housing units.
And if you go to the link there, if you go
to the following URL, you can actually get
a sample C404 form.
And this is the form that gets sent out to
the building permit officials.
And this is the form that they fill in.
So you can actually have a look and
understand the survey design and the form
that they need to fill in.
So a bit of background information there.
Basically, the building permit survey
covers all permit issuing places in the
United States, which are jurisdictions
that issue building or zoning permits.
And you can see the amount of permits.
And you can see the amount of permits
issuing places throughout the history of
the data set.
And the data set goes back to 1959.
And you can see way back in 1959, you can
see our sample size for the data, which is
10,000 permit issuing places.
So that's 10,000 jurisdictions that were
issuing building or zoning permits.
And you can see it's been growing and
they've increased the sample size over
time.
And the last count of the sample size was
back in 2014, where they had over 20,000
building or zoning permit jurisdictions,
which were issuing building permits.
Now, we do have the entire data set in the
downloads area.
But if you do want to go and get that
yourself, you need to go to the URL,
census.gov forward slash construction, NRC
index.
And you click on the left-hand side,
building permit survey, you look for new
residential construction,
and you click on building permit survey.
This is the monthly report that you get.
And you can download the full report in
PDF format, or you can do that in Excel as
well.
And if you download it in Excel, this is
essentially what you're looking for.
You're looking for new privately owned
housing units authorized by building
permits in permit issuing places.
And this is the download for December
2020.
And what you're looking for is the tab or
the sheet inside the file called units SA.
So units seasonally adjusted.
So what does this number actually
represent?
Well, the 1704, that is 1.7 million
building permits authorized or issued in
December 2020.
So remember, this number will have been
coming out in the second or third week of
January.
Okay. And if you look to the right-hand
side, you can see the various regions of
the United States.
You can see the Northeast, Midwest, South
and West.
So the survey breaks it up into four areas
of the United States.
And you can see a total number for each.
So for example, in the Northeast, you can
see 140.
That's 140,000 permits issued.
You can see in the Midwest, 248.
You can see in the South, 881.
And in the West, 435.
And if you add those totals together, you
get the total number for the US.
So 1.7 million building permits issued for
the month of December.
Now within those four regions that are
defined by the Census Bureau, you can
actually go a little bit
deeper and you can look at the permits by
each state within the United States.
If you go to the website, go to Building
Permits Survey, and you'll be taken to
some links that you can click on and you
can look at permits by state.
When you download the data, this is what
it's going to look like.
You'll get a spreadsheet that looks like
this.
You can obviously see we've got in this
sample here, we've got the headline number
on the top
for the United States and we've got our
regions that we just looked at.
So we've got our Northeast region.
So if you look in column A, we have our
Northeast region, we have our Midwest
region,
we have our South region, and we have our
West region at the bottom.
These are, additionally, these regions are
broken up into divisions.
So you can see, for example, and we've
highlighted a few states on the screen
here.
So a few key pivotal states, obviously,
New York and Florida.
You can see New York is part of the
Mid-Atlantic division, which is part of
the Northeast region.
And Florida is part of the South Atlantic
division, which is part of the South
region.
So if you're really interested in looking
at what's happening at the state level,
there's obviously important information
that can be gleaned from that from time to
time.
The biggest places that you need to be
looking at are obviously in the US, New
York, Florida,
Texas and California.
When the monthly data comes out, it's not
only useful from a trading and portfolio
management perspective
to look at the headline number for the
whole of the United States, but to
potentially understand
where any growth and contraction is coming
from at a state level.
But for the purposes of this video and the
PTM video series, we're going to be
looking only at the headline
rate of the United States as our main
gauge.
So let's have a look at an example of
building permits in recent history.
What we've got on the screen here is the
period June 2018 to December 2020,
which if you think back to video seven
with the ISM and other videos, we looked
at this period,
the period August 2018 to August 2019.
And if you remember, that was the period
when the ISM peaked, so in August 2018,
and then went into slowdown.
If you recall what was going on in the
money markets during that period from
August 18 to August 19,
the yield curve began flattening, then the
short end of the curve inverted slightly
versus the middle.
So we had a slight inversion of the yield
curve there.
And that occurs up until spring 2019.
And if you recall, the selloff in the S&P
happened between October 2018 and January
2019.
And the selloff was approximately 17 or
18%.
And if you recall, when we took a snapshot
of the tens and twos in August 2019,
there was slight inversion, but
essentially flat, but slight inversion.
And the ISM was below 50 for the first
time.
Now, as you probably recall, the Fed saw
the problem coming and they cut rates in
July,
then in September and October 2019, in
response to the money markets chaos
and the ISM manufacturing slowdown.
Now, if we look at permits during this
period, so August 18 to July 19.
So leading into the August 19 ISM and
yield curve inversion.
If we look during that period, August 18
up until July 19,
we can see that building permits
essentially didn't grow at all.
So if you look on the screen, in August
2018, permits were reported at 1.258
million by June 2019.
And remember, that June number will have
been reported in the second or third week
of July.
That June number is 1.273 million building
permits issued.
So essentially no growth over that period,
so essentially flat.
But what's interesting is what happens to
building permits in July 2019 and beyond.
So remember, the Fed cut rates in July and
the July building permits number will have
been reported in the second or third week
of August.
So what we can see on the screen very
obviously is that in response to the Fed
rate cuts, permits taking off almost
immediately.
We get a reading in July 2019, reported in
the second, third week of August.
We get a reading in July 19 of 1.366
million building permits issued.
And then in August, we get 1.471 million
building permits issued.
And we see growth continuing up until
February 2020, when we see the COVID
shutdowns start to take effect on the
housing market and building permits
issued.
And in March 2020, we see building permits
go down again and then they hit a low in
April 2020.
And then they start to go higher in May,
struggling around May and June at around
the same level at 1.2 million, 1.25
million.
And then in July, they start to take off
again.
So July 2020, and then we have a continual
rise throughout the year of 2020 for the
rest of the year.
Now, obviously, during that time, we had a
massive intervention from the Federal
Reserve during that period, during the
COVID lockdowns.
But something else was going on as well,
there was a consumer or human response,
which also helped precipitate a boom in
permits.
The lockdowns, so the extended draconian
COVID lockdowns resulted in a big increase
in interstate migration.
So that's New Yorkers moving to Florida,
mostly, and Californians moving to Texas.
There was a big increase in interstate
migration.
So that combined with record low interest
rates and big increases in the money
supply, plus the Fed and government
stability packages created incremental
demand for new housing and mortgage
refinancing.
And if you recall as well, the Fed's
actions definitely steepened the yield
curve, and the S&P 500 during that time
rallied very, very hard.
But interestingly, if we think about
looking at periods in time and what was
actually going on at those moments in
time, if we think of that period, August
18 to August 19, that we've looked at in
previous videos,
when we look at building permits, August
18 to the June report, which was reported
in July 19, if we think of building
permits, yes, they didn't go up.
Yes, they were flat.
But guess what, there was actually no
collapse.
So imagine yourself sitting at that moment
in time, analysing this building permits
data and all of the other leading
indicators, and every week you're getting
new and more and more information.
So in that period, August 18 to June 19,
there was no collapse in building permits.
The S&P 500 sold off between October 18
and January 19 of around 17-18%, and the
ISM was in decline from peak.
And the ISM manufacturing number did go
below 50 for the first time in August 19.
But if you recall, when we looked at the
UMCSI, the consumer data, there wasn't a
collapse in consumer spending.
And also in the services sector, there was
no collapse in the service sector either.
So remember, when we looked at the ISM
non-manufacturing report.
So there were signs there, guys, that even
though the ISM, the manufacturing number,
was in decline from peak and went below 50
for the first time in August 19,
the US consumer building permits and the
services sector hadn't collapsed.
They were holding up and they were still
very strong.
The Fed took action because of stresses in
the bond market and because of a
manufacturing slowdown in the US.
Building permits actually held steady
throughout, similar to the US consumer,
the UMCSI and the US services sector.
So this is a good example, guys, of
looking at a moment in history and looking
at a leading indicator and putting it into
the context during that moment in history
with what was going on in the economy
overall and in the context of what was
happening with other leading indicators.
By going back in time and looking at
trends and turning points in economic
history in the business cycle and putting
it into context with what was happening in
the economy and with other leading
indicators at the time,
what you're actually doing is you're
becoming a student of business cycle
history and economic history and what
you're actually doing is you're honing
your skills for understanding leading
indicators and understanding the economy.
So in the future, when you actually sit
down at any one point in time and you look
at a particular leading indicator and a
collection of them and you look at the
context of what is occurring in the world
and in the economy at the time because
you've practiced and looked at past
business cycles and understand business
cycle history,
you're going to understand what is
happening in the current context at any
one moment in time a hell of a lot better
than somebody who has no idea what's going
on at all.
This is obviously where you can get an
edge in the market.
Now, when it comes to building permits and
the history of the data, we put together
the all time permits chart here and this
is available in the downloads area.
And you can denote some very obvious
visual traits of the building permits data
when looking at the chart.
Very obviously, there's peaks and troughs.
We've also put a long term average trend
line on the chart.
So visually, you can see the long term
average trend line is between 1.3 million
and 1.4 million.
You can also see that there's, if we look
at troughs at the bottom of the chart, you
can also see that visually there's some
very obvious levels for troughs in
building permits data.
You can see 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 data points
before the global financial crisis where
building permits were essentially between
7,000 and 800,000 where they troughed in
previous business cycles.
And then in the global financial crisis,
building permits bottomed in the low
500,000 and we're bottoming basically
between 500,000 and 600,000 permits
issued.
When we look at the peaks, we can
basically see peaks at 2 million permits
and above throughout the permits data
history.
So for example, if you look at the global
financial crisis going into it, you can
see that permits were above the 2 million
mark for quite a long time.
Essentially, permits were above 2 million
for most of 2004 and all of 2005 and the
beginning part of 2006.
It was in May 2006 when permits actually
fell below 2 million and then they went
below 1.9 million in June 2006.
So that's pretty amazing because when we
think about earlier, when we looked at our
lead times for permits to starts and then
completions,
we denoted that building permits were
leading 12 to 16 months on completions.
And this time period is born out here if
you look at the channel for the upswing in
housing permits from the early 90s all the
way up to 2006.
The channel was broken and we were being
warned about a big slowdown in the housing
market, a very meaningful slowdown in the
housing market in the United States in May
and June 2006.
And that time horizon is born out because
the financial crisis happened or started
happening 12 months later.
And then 16, 18 months later, that's when
the financial crisis really started to get
going in the second half of 2007.
In more recent history, you can see on the
right hand side of the chart, permits
coming out of the financial crisis where
they troughed in the low 500s.
And then permits going up consistently in
that channel.
And apart from a blip up, an aggressive
blip up in 2015, permits didn't really
recover back to the long term average
trend line of between 13, 1.3 million and
1.4 million.
Until 2016, 2017.
So it took a long time for the housing
market to recover to a long term average
trend in terms of building permits coming
out of the financial crisis.
And looking at very recent history, we can
obviously see that periods that we were
looking at in 2018, 2019 and 2020, where
we have the building permits number above
long term trend, quite significantly above
and then coming down in 2020 for the COVID
collapse and then rallying after the COVID
reopening.
So you can go back in the downloads area
into the data, not just looking at the
chart, but also looking at the actual
columns and rows with all the data in it
and just have a scroll through, have a
look at previous lows and peaks.
So previous drops and peaks in building
permits, put them into context, put them
into context of what was going on at the
time in the economy and also what was
happening with other leading indicators.
Become a student of the business cycle.
Something else that's in the downloads
area is the building permits month on
month percentage change.
And that's with all data history.
If you look at the bottom of the chart,
you can see the percentage change on the
right hand side.
So on the right hand axis and the changes
are denoted visually to help visually with
positives in green and negatives in red.
And you can see peaks and troughs in that
type of performance as well on the month
on month changes, percentage changes in
the data.
So you can see, for example, when we have
a monthly change that's at 20% or above,
that tends to be a monthly move where we
don't see moves after that following as
big as that move.
So a plus 20% in the positives.
And in the negatives, it's the same, but a
negative 20%.
Whenever we get a month that's negative
20% change in building permits, months
that follow are not that extreme.
We've also, in the downloads area, got
data and got the charts for building
permits compared to GDP growth.
So here we're looking at a year on year
percentage change in building permits
versus year on year percentage change of
GDP growth.
And you can clearly see that when building
permits is in the positives, we're getting
GDP growth growing in the same direction
in the positives.
And when building permit changes, year on
year go negative soon after we see GDP
growth year on year percentage going in
the same direction and going negative.
But not all the time.
So we don't look at this chart and say
there's a rule book.
What we have to do is always use the data
in conjunction with other leading
indicators as well.
Of course, if we see building permits year
on year percentage changes going negative,
we take note of that and we look at it in
the context of other leading indicators
and what's happening in the economy.
We don't have a rule book which says GDP
growth will absolutely be negative if
building permits year on year percentage
change is negative.
And we also don't have a rule book for
exactly what's going to happen in the
direction it's going to be and the actual
magnitude of a move as well.
And also, there isn't a rule book for the
exact time lag.
Everything has to be taken into context.
What we've also done when we look at
building permits leading the S&P 500,
we've also done a useful exercise here of
looking at the 12 month moving average of
building permits year on year percentage
change.
So we've taken that same data, the year on
year percentage change, and we're looking
at a 12 month moving average of that data
and comparing it to a 12 month moving
average of the S&P 500 year on year
percentage data, putting that on the same
chart.
And visually, you can see from this
exercise that they both move in the same
direction, sometimes at the same time and
sometimes with a time lag where permits is
leading the S&P 500 direction and
potential S&P 500 annual year on year
percentage change.
But again, there's no definitive rule book
here that says if permits are doing
something like breaking to the upside to
go into the positive in terms of year on
year percentage change or breaking to the
downside of year on year percentage
change, but we have to do a certain action
in the S&P 500.
So permits, again, permits, again, have to
be taken into context with everything else
or other leading indicators.
And that overall should give us a very,
very good idea of the directional bias
that we would have in our portfolios and
potentially what to be long and what to be
short in our portfolios.
Now, you'll also find in the downloads
area in the spreadsheet that we've got the
data there for housing starts.
And we've got the data also for housing
completions in your own time.
You can go through that data, but we've
got the visuals there as well for you.
So you can learn about the data and the
data history and also how to put these
charts together.
And you can also, obviously, on a monthly
basis, use these spreadsheets.
And when you update your data, update your
charts.
So that will be something you'll be doing
on a monthly basis.
And yes, that's the self-starter
mentality, guys.
This is showing up regularly to get
consistent returns in your portfolio.
Guess what?
You're going to have to show up
consistently and do the work.
Now, I mentioned earlier about the global
financial crisis, 2008, 2009.
Let's have a little look at a bit of
business cycle history.
And again, go through this exercise of
looking at turning points and trends in a
leading indicator.
Let's have a look at building permits and
what was going on back then.
Obviously, if we're going to be analyzing
building permits and attempting to gauge
its usefulness as a leading indicator,
the most obvious place to look in business
cycle history would actually be the
housing crash of 2008, 2009.
And you can see on the chart when we look
at the data for building permits.
So in the second column, you can see that
building permits, the low was 521,000
seasonally adjusted annualized rate in
April, 2009.
And remember, that will have been reported
in May.
And if we fast forward a bit in time, we
can see the building permits number
getting stronger, but it's struggling
essentially.
And then there was a near term high put in
for the month of March, 2010, which was
687,000 seasonally adjusted annualized
rate.
And the number then goes lower.
And it really struggles for a long time.
And that's basically because there were so
many homes that were on the market.
And there was a lot of inventory to get
through, especially foreclosures.
And it took a long time for new homes.
So building permits to come back to the
level it was even in 2010.
So the permits number, the breakout was
actually around February 2012, where we
had three months in a row of breaking the
previous April 2010 resistance, which gave
us confirmation that we had a breakout.
And that was almost a full two years after
the high was put in post the trough in
April 2010.
So the high was put in in April 2010, post
the trough.
So we had the trough March 09, 521,000.
We had the March 2010 report, which is
reported in April 2010, which came out at
687,000.
And then it took a full almost two years
to get back above that level.
Now, putting this into a bit of context of
what was going on elsewhere.
If you recall back to the US consumer
video, the UMCSI video, where we
highlighted that the US consumer, after
the global financial crisis, didn't really
recover until the first half of 2012.
So if you recall, QE2 was terminated June
29, 2012 by the Fed on the right hand
side.
This was the data screenshot from the
UMCSI video.
And we can see this was when in Jan and
Feb 2012, where we see the UMCSI breaking
above 70 and implying GDP growth somewhere
between 0 and 2% for the year.
And guess what?
This is exactly the time when building
permits broke to the upside, as we've seen
in December, Jan, Feb.
So December 2011 and Jan and Feb 2012.
So it happened at the same time.
And so taken together, you know, when we
put these things into context, using
consumer sentiment and permits together,
it's a powerful combination of leading
indicators to predict GDP growth and S&P
500 direction and returns.
And coincidentally, yes, at the same time,
this is when home builder stocks took off.
So this is the XHB, which is the home
builder ETF in the United States.
And you can see here on the chart, we've
gone back to the beginning of 2012.
And we've highlighted this area in red.
You can see the XHB ETF.
That's when it breaks to the upside and
then goes up aggressively from that level.
And you can see from the chart, it goes up
to the end of 2013, where we get from the
level 20 in around March 2012.
By the end of 2013, we are up on the XHB
to a level of 33.
So that's 13 points change from a level of
20, which is about two thirds, about 65%.
And actually, if you look at the chart,
you can see it reached around the 33 level
around May, June 2013.
So we're looking at a 65% move in a little
over of a year, which is obviously a
pretty big move for the housing sector.
And don't forget, you know, this is the
XHB ETF.
There will obviously be plenty of housing
stocks in there that will have both
outperformed and gone up a lot more than
65%.
And those that are underperformed and went
up less than 65%.
So again, when we look at a leading
indicator like building permits, and we
look at business cycle history, and we
look at what was going on with other
leading indicators, we put things into
context.
And we also look at what was going on in
the market at the time as well.
It's a very useful exercise for us to do
this, for us to understand it, because
it's going to hone our skills.
And we will become much better at making
more informed decisions in the future
whenever we're sitting in a moment in time
and analysing a particular leading
indicator in the context of the wider
economy, other leading indicators, and the
stock market.
So let's summarize here, let's summarize
why building permits are important to us.
As traders and portfolio managers, it's
obviously a very important number, the
building permits number, to our outlook
for predicting US GDP growth.
So direction of GDP growth, and therefore
the direction and potential annual returns
in the S&P 500.
They are a leading indicator, building
permits are leading both housing starts
and completions.
So completions follow housing starts, and
housing starts follow permits.
However, there is a lot more useful
information that we can glean from the
building permits number.
It doesn't only tell us likely future GDP
direction, and therefore likely economic
conditions and direction of the S&P.
Permits also tell us whether developers
are bullish or bearish on the prospects of
the housing sector.
So a combination of developer financing,
so their demand and forecast for housing,
but also whether consumers demand housing.
So it gives us a good gauge on mortgage
liquidity.
So taken together, all in all, this means
the building permits number tells us the
liquidity and health of the US banking and
credit sector and the potential for a
change in consumer spending habits.
Now something it also does, obviously, the
Fed is looking at this stuff too.
Building permits also tells us what we
should expect from the Fed in terms of
likely policy response.
So by using monthly building permits in
conjunction with our money market leading
indicators and other macro indicators like
our other surveys, we will have a very
good understanding of the US economy,
money flows and potential Fed policy.
So like the other surveys we've looked at,
and our money market leading indicators,
you have to use this on a monthly basis to
understand what's going on and to make
more informed decisions.
And yes, guys, we're going to have a quick
throwback to ITPM principles.
You have to have a self starter mentality.
Firstly, what you should be doing is using
the leading indicator data that we've got
in all the download areas and analyze
business cycles and their moving parts
throughout history.
Become a student of business cycle
history, become a student of business
cycle history, and then you need to show
up regularly.
You need to be consistent.
You need to utilize all the leading
indicators in conjunction with each other
on a monthly basis to get a picture of the
economy for your portfolio direction.
You need to become proficient at data
collection and investigation.
So learn about money markets and surveys
and how they work in detail to get an
appreciation of what the numbers mean.
So when you analyze the data at any moment
in time, when it comes out and it's live
and it's real and the market is trading,
you have an edge over those people in the
market that have no idea.
You can then predict the future and get
positioned for the future when others
can't.
Now, interpretation of the numbers is
obviously way more important than just
knowing what the number is.
So again, become a student of business
cycle history.
You must always be asking yourself when
you look at any particular leading
indicator and the numbers come out and
it's live.
How does it fit into the bigger picture
context?
So not just the number in absolute
context, but in the context of what's
going on with other leading indicators and
the bigger picture of what's going on with
those leading indicators and the economy
as a whole at that moment in time.
So we looked at building permits as an
example, not collapsing during 2019.
And that was the period where that was
happening in conjunction with no S&P 500
bear market.
And that may have led us to conclude that
when the Fed cut rates at a 0-1 S&P versus
GDP growth quarter had just occurred.
So where the S&P went down, so where the
S&P went down, but GDP growth stayed
positive.
We may have been sitting there in that
time as a student of business cycle
history, looking at building permits not
collapsing during that time.
And then no official 20% correction, bear
market in the S&P 500.
And looking at the other leading
indicators, such as UMCSI, so the consumer
not collapsing, and also the service
sector not collapsing.
And we may have looked at that and made
the decision, this is the time to get long
or to have a long bias in the portfolio.
So it's vitally important that you do this
and analyze business cycle history, what
was going on at the time, to really
sharpen yourself.
So when in the future you are looking at
leading indicators when they're coming
out, you make very well informed
decisions.
The more you know, and the more you
practice at interpretation, the pieces
come together and you will make more well
informed and better decisions on the
direction of your portfolio.
And of course, when you have the
information, you interpret it well, you're
going to make decisions with a much higher
level of confidence.
Additionally, a better understanding of
the macroeconomic backdrop is going to
allow you to generate better single stock
trade ideas.
So not just the directional bias of your
portfolio.
Of course, knowing the net direction your
portfolio should be at any one time is
pretty damn important.
But just as important is making sure you
are long and short, the right stocks, the
right stuff.
If you are net long, for example, but long
all of the stuff that isn't going up, then
of course you failed to make money.
The information hasn't led to a profit.
And that's what we are in this business to
do.
We are here to make money.
So we obviously want to turn this
information into profit.
Now, of course, later in the video series,
we're going to be looking in a lot more
detail at the process to generate trade
ideas on a consistent basis.
We're going to obviously as well continue
with our macroeconomic analysis for
direction for the moment.
So don't worry about trade ideas.
That's coming up later in the video
series.
In terms of ITPM principles, just a
reminder of the four ITPM principles,
self-sustainability, work ethic, free
information, work smart, not hard.
If you stick to the principles
religiously, you stand a very good chance
of hitting your objective of getting
consistent profitability.
If you don't, or even worse, do the
opposite, there's a very high chance
you're never going to meet this objective.
When you show up regularly each month and
analyze and interpret the macro leading
indicators, you are adhering to these
principles and you're going to make better
trading decisions than the vast majority
of retail traders on the planet.
So don't be scared of doing the work,
guys.
This is just something that has to be
done.
What you're also learning here is
literally the job of a professional
trader.
This is what we do, okay?
We are students of the business cycle and
we diligently go through macro economic
indicators on a monthly basis.
And we're constantly trying to figure out
what our buyers should be in our portfolio
and what we should be long and what we
should be short.
You are learning this job now, and this is
how it's done on the professional side.
And now you can replicate it on the retail
side in your retail trading infrastructure
and your trading account.
So don't be scared of the work, guys.
This is the job.
This is what has to be done every month.
Okay, so we are done with building permits
here.
Let's go over to the next video where
we're going to be looking at small
businesses.
Thank you.